what's up guys right now I have in front
of me the new Xbox one s and we are
going to unbox it and it doesn't even
come out until August
I'm so excited apparently somebody's
already might've unbox for me but that's
okay so I don't even need a knife
all right
I'm just kidding
open this up first
where's the power brick not here because
you don't need it here's the new
controller it looks so good
new controller some batteries very
important and now we have all been
waiting for
got some games in there Mike you want to
save that it's so tiny
- it looks so good
you get in the shot check out the ports
here in the back
Aaron do you want to come join me for
this unboxing great how are you doing
good so we're here at e3 and we we
actually I wish you guys can see this
but we actually love to show them we had
everybody holding up their iPod liking
so that we would be able to see but what
we've got here is the new Xbox one as
now what's the actual release date so
it's coming out in August we're taking
pre-orders now 500 gigabyte version
starts at 299 okay
349 for one terabyte and now for the
first time ever two terabytes for 399
and then it does enable 4k video
streaming so for Netflix so that's a 4k
blu-ray player built-in you'll notice
it's actually also for the magic number
of 40% smaller a lot of people are using
it for TV so we have HDMI IN and HDMI
out so you can plug in your cable
satellite you have an antenna all that
we have two USB ports an IR blaster
optical audio and Ethernet so despite
all the reduction in size we've got a
lot of great functionality there people
wanted to be able to pair the
controllers right in the front so we
have that button here we have an IR
blaster so if using it for more
entertainment or using a universal
remote that'll work well there and then
the button you'll know is now done just
touch sensitives you have to push it in
yeah and it'll light up versus the
current Xbox one where you have to slide
your finger over ya can do it both
horizontal or vertical
yeah we stand it like this here you can
see here it's also we got the logo here
you can scan it up as well
and then it'll fit like in a computer
bag or messenger bag which is kind of
nice so portability is you know
realistic versus you know the current
models much larger as you said the power
brick is built in this dealer power
program so the giant brick is gone well
the good news - I'll see you guys
announced I think I guess I guess you
can call the partnership with Windows
head because basically you guys can kind
of have a platform yes and so that's a
great thing about like this controller
it has Bluetooth built in so you can use
this across Windows 10 and Xbox one
mainly yes so your accessories are
compatible all of our first party games
that we're making will be Xbox plan your
title so you can buy them once on Xbox
and play them both on Windows 10 and
Xbox one or not automatically syncs your
saves and a lot of them are also
enabling cross play so you'll be able to
play with people that are on the PC and
gets people on the console as well
is this the only one
or the previous this one is bluetooth
but it's new but also the Xbox design
lab controller is the same model so if
you go and create your own controller
you'll give the new Bluetooth model and
then this has increased range for us as
well as new textured grips which is some
of the other feedback Weaver we largely
kept the same design the mill people
a lot of people are getting 4k TVs a lot
of us for continued support HDR so this
will also enable HDR campaign so for
Gears of War you'll get the full
high-tech high dynamic range benefits
for scalebound a number of our titles
will support each gear as well should we
go check out the design lab now think
that'd be a good idea I think it's a
great idea
let's go so now in the Xbox design lab
how many configurations can you make
eight million different colors and
options you can change the buttons
colors on the buttons here they're clear
the d-pad the bumpers the sticks you can
make good or bad decisions depending on
you can just go crazy you know if you
have a favorite school or a favorite
game or whenever and you can laser
engrave your gamertag on here as well
but the question is Justine what are you
going to do basically
woman in Norway so I get control oh did
you customize on yes I did it is it's
gone oh I did I did I did black on black
on black on black on black I did pink on
pink on pink okay so go figure
it works all right guys that was the
Xbox design lab and the Xbox one has on
his boxing I'm just so excited I don't
even have any word happy guys later
should I do an unboxing can I get him
real again I probably will
okay bye hey guys just up today's the
first day of e3 and I'm super excited
right now we're kicking it off with the
first press conference of the day it's
the Xbox press covers